ces vidéos sont posées par rhinoshield
vous avez moins 60 % et le Black Friday
et encore dix pour-cent de moi avec le
code Cyrus BF plus d'informations en fin
de vidéo c'est une question compliqué on
parle de la vie humaine
dès le début la question je suis
beaucoup trop large mais même en
restreignant ça reste une question
compliquée et qu'on pourrait faire qu'on
peut pas je te ferai quelque chose comme
la vie et pourtant tout autour de nous
il y a des chiffres qui nous rappelle
que même si on se rend pas forcément
content
la vie et peut-être chiffre par exemple
vous êtes sur l'autoroute et voyez un
panneau sens de kilomètres qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire bah ça veut dire que je
suis en train de kilomètres heure il y a
tellement de morts que c'est trop
dangereux ok donc on veut pas qu'on y
aille par contre on est en train de
kilomètres il y en a pas assez pour
qu'on se dise qu'on va baisser la
limitation alors que si on était limité
à 30 km heure et ben il y aurait zéro
accident ou presque donc on voit bien
que il y a une sorte de seuil qui donne
une sœur de valeur à la vie et donc ça
ça me permet de pas vouloir forcément
tout le temps éviter la mort et
heureusement quoi parce que sinon en
fait il y aura pas de trottoir
on voudrait pas d'alcool par exemple on
peut pas se baigner en mer enfin bref il
y a plein de choses qu'on pourrait pas
faire ça n'a aucun sens et là je vois
venir vous dit peut-être pas assez un
petit peu ce qu'on a fait avec le colis
est-ce qu'on peut encore parfois je te
dirai limiter sa liberté pour éviter la
mort quoi
et surtout pas avec les mesures qui qui
n'ont pas vraiment de sens où ils sont
vraiment chelou quoi comme par exemple
s'autoriser soi-même à sortir de chez
soi par un papier et qu'on l'a fait
quand même parce que on a estimé que
nous activités de la vie quotidienne
était moins importante que le nombre de
vie qui était en retard du coup comment
on peut calculer 7 arbitrage est-ce
qu'on a pas besoin de savoir combien
vaut une vie
bah on a déjà un prix c'est 550000 € en
fait en additionnant tous les organes on
arrive à ce prix après ça dépend de la
cam ça dépend de la provenance par
exemple le rein d'un Américain il vaut
17 fois plus que leur indien indien un
cœur ça vaut 120000 dollars donc ça
c'est cher par contre si vous avez
besoin d'un avant-bras ça vaut que 320
dollars voilà on sait jamais on sait
jamais on peut avoir besoin d'un
avant-bras un moment voilà pas cher 350
dollars HT 3
cl = je t'ai pas d'avant-bras ok mais si
on va plus loin que ça te réponds très
terre-à-terre on va se rend compte qu'il
y a eu plusieurs approche pour
déterminer une réponse à cette question
est ensemble on va voir trois la
première c'est celle de Michel le net
est dans sa famille parce que sinon ça
ferait quoi
laisse-moi Michel Sarran au fond c'est
un français et son truc c'est la
sécurité routière la santé et l'éthique
c'est un petit peu monsieur combien vaut
une vie c'est Monsieur le net Michel le
net
c'est pas vraiment monsieur combien vaut
une vie sur son serment habitable en 94
Michel il se base sur les travaux de
Claude Abraham et Jacques Tillier deux
ingénieur pour mettre au point une
formule formule elle permet de se rendre
compte du coup que fait la société lors
d'un décès prématuré et donc voir ce
qu'il faut mettre en place pour éviter
ce décès avec par exemple la sécurité
routière au revoir ce que la société
serais prête à défoncer en fait pour
garder cette nuit il va chercher trois
critères les perds direct donc ça c'est
des pertes qui sont directement liée au
décès donc ça dire par exemple des frais
d'hospitalisation
assurance réparation potentiel frais de
justice et que c'est les pertes liés aux
productions que la personne aurait
produite si elle était rester en vie et
pour les inactifs on intègre une
probabilité pour qu'il reçoit les pertes
affective c'est-à-dire préjudice moral
c'est des sommes que touche les proches
pour compenser la perte d'un défunt je
t'ai pas du tout au courant de ça et
même un tableau gens hyper précis par
exemple vous perdez un frère ou une sœur
au Pérou écouter le dernier MacBook Pro
monte au max quoi donc donc tout ça ça
fait la formule suivante et en
appliquant cette formule il arrive à une
moyenne de la vie humaine en France en
93 de 550000 € ça c'est marrant c'est
exactement le chiffre que je vous ai
donné tout à l'heure en additionnant les
organes et pour info c'est l'approche
Michel la appeler production perdu brut
apprécié notre vie vaut ce qu'on
coûterait à la société au moment notre
mort bah ça veut dire qu'il y a des gens
qui ont une vie qui vaut très cher et
d'autres qui ont une vie qui vaut rien
du tout en fait par exemple si elle
meurt dans un accident de fusée ce qu'on
lui souhaite pas il va y avoir
énormément déjà deux direct
et cetera
parce que là quand même 6 enfants le
petit coquinou et
tout ce qui est production futur perdu
donc les productions qui va pas pouvoir
produire
sinon il a pleins d'entreprises qui font
plein d'innovation et cetera là on est
sur une vie qui vaut plusieurs milliards
si on suit le raison de Michel par
contre si un caissier de Franprix par
exemple qui est célibataire qui n'a pas
d'enfants marche tombe sur le trottoir
se casse la tête sur toi et meurt bon
bah là ce dans ce calcul là ça vaut pas
grand-chose ça c'est que j'aurais du mal
à dire non qu'est-ce qui est par exemple
on sait pas ce qui peut se passer dans
quelques années il peut rejoindre une
asso et en fait genre exceller dans ce
truc et décrocher un prix Nobel de la
paix j'en sais rien
mais on ne sait pas on peut pas savoir
s'il y a pas d'autres méthodes en stock
il y a une autre technique il vient du
secteur médical qui n'est pas basé sur
une concession monétaire mais elle va
aller sur une unité qui s'appelle le
coin en quoi les pourquoi l'été à Just
Like You en français années de vie
pondérée par la qualité la qualité de la
vie des individus que je sais que c'est
pas forcément la vie mais la qualité de
la vie la vie à différents et à tous les
états ne se valent pas certain serai
peut-être même pire que la mort c'est
pour ça que il y a certains pays qui
legalise l'euthanasie Paris comment ça
va en fait et ben c'est très sympa on a
multiplié d'un côté l'espérance de vie
qui nous reste est la qualité de vie
c'est un indice qui va de 0 à 1 en gros
vous avez une santé incroyable de ouf 0
vous êtes mort
donc si vous êtes par exemple 50 ans à
vivre mais que vous avez une qualité de
vie un peu naze des on adore, et en fait
votre Cali sera de 25 il a que 50 x 0,5
ça fait 20 ans il sert notamment quand
des médecins doivent prendre des
décisions voilà les décisions médicales
savoir qui sauve et comment et cetera
mais ça ah non ça c'est limite au point
où depuis 2010 après une étude de la
Commission européenne la technique n'est
plus recommencer ses limites elles ont
été fait un expliquer par UNO jane
philosophe français c'est pas mal penché
sur les questions moral dans dans son
livre l'influence des croissants chauds
sur la bonté humaine
en quoi le titre j'ai envie de lire ces
bouquins le mec aurait été trop fort sur
Youtube en terme de titre miniature une
machine Bruel imagine un chirurgien qui
fait face à 5 mourant qui ont chacun
besoin d'une greffe différentes
une journée de merde visiblement et un
nouvel arrivant un nouveau patient qui
c'est juste voulait l'acheter mais après
quelques analyses on se rend compte que
il est compatible avec les 5 mois et
bien si on raisonne en colis
c'est-à-dire en maximisation des état de
santé de la société et ben il faudrait
se sacrifier 7e personne pour en fait
utiliser les différents parties de ton
corps
pour sauver les 5 autres alors que quand
on s'est foulé la cheville et que on va
à l'hôpital je pars on s'attend plus à
la limite un plâtre vraiment max en vrai
que quand on sait pas faire son à
l'hôpital d'ailleurs donc finalement
mesurer la vie en quoi lis éthiquement
c'est peut-être pas le plus quali
mon comment l'observe juge est la valeur
d'une vie c'est compliqué du coup on
peut se poser une question au lieu de
juger la valeur d'une vie on va se poser
la question de la valeur de ma vie c'est
ce qu'on appelle la DAP disposition à
payer et c'est la méthode la plus
répandue pour attribuer une valeur a une
demi des plutôt simple il essaie de
demander aux gens qui sont prêts à payer
pour réduire leur chant de mourir et
donc bah gagner de l'espérance de vie
donc la réponse des gens on obtient des
valeurs qui sont différentes parce que
ça là ça dépend la perception de chacun
et donc on peut faire une moyenne pour
avoir une valeur global en me disant
c'est technique le rapport boîte en 2001
arrive à la conclusion que en moyenne la
valeur de la vie d'un Français et de 1,5
million d'euros le souci en faisant
estimer la valeur de la vie individu bah
c'est que les êtres humains sont biaisé
en fait par exemple certaines personnes
peuvent avoir ce qu'on appelle une
inversion au risque que vraiment ils
veulent éviter le risque le plus
possible et donc ils sont prêts à payer
une fortune pour pour éviter le moins de
risques et donc réduire très légèrement
leur chance de mourir et à l'inverse et
des gens qui ont un goût du risque qui
sont prêts à augmenter leur exposition
au risque mais pour vraiment une faible
somme d'argent pour autant est-ce que ça
veut dire que la vie d'une personne qui
a une inversion risque elle vaut plus
que la vie d'une personne qui a un goût
du risque non c'est juste que ces 2
personnes-là sont pas vraiment réaliste
par rapport aux enjeux donc encore une
fois la technique n'est pas où et on
voit qu'il y a des limites pendant cette
valeur elle existe et d'ailleurs selon
Ariel colonomos chercheur spécialisé
dans les relations et l'éthique de la
guerre elle est même en train de monter
à l'heure pourquoi je pourrai pas monter
descendre un petit peu comme une action
bourse en fait finalement et en fait
selon Ariel elle augmente parce que on
le voit genre depuis plusieurs années
déjà la valeur de la et de plus en plus
considéré et c'est visible à autour de
nous par exemple en France il y a 70 ans
bah voilà c'était la guerre est vraiment
la mort fait partie du quotidien et là
depuis des années on a vraiment pas une
paix durable en fait sur notre
territoire on a des avancées
technologiques de malade on a une
médecine de pointe
même là il y a eu une crise sanitaire
bat très vite on a été capable de
répondre avec un vaccin pour limiter les
morts et cetera donc mourir c'est devenu
moins facile qu'avant du coup bah ce
chiffre de la valeur de la vie il
augmente et la question c'est juste que
en fait on veut dire scénario on peut
imaginer un scénario où
finalement il y a de nouvelles guerres
dessous de nouvelles formes il y a aussi
de plus en plus de crise sanitaire
exetera et donc de nouveau cette valeur
baisse on peut imaginer que ce prix ne
cesse d'augmenter jusqu'à un moment en
fait on va presque trop dépenser pour
sauvegarder des vies pire que ça à faire
au détriment de trop de choses et en fin
d'année scénario on eradic la mort c'est
qu'en fait la médecine devient tellement
avancé que on ils ont tous régénérer
tout remplacer et en fait on peut vivre
quasiment indéfiniment
paradoxalement bah si on eradic la mort
Pahlavi est la plus grande valeur en
fait parce que si on veut la perdre ça
veut dire que c'est un choix car on a
choisi et finalement le fait que la vie
n'est pas de valeur bah c'est ce qui est
le plus en accord avec peut-être
une certaine manière la nature et la
logique parce que si on s'arrête à
l'instant et couper abstraction bah
voilà de la société de la culture de la
religion de plein de choses
et qu'on reprend un petit peu à notre
place dans le monde dans l'univers de ce
qu'on représente dans le cosmos
on n'est rien du tout quoi nous dit
c'est petit c'est extrêmement délimité
dans le temps enfin par rapport au temps
de du cosmos
c'est totalement négligeable
on a rien quoi donc on peut s'amuser à
mettre des prix exetera sur à l'univers
Aixam ça n'a pas de sens on en a besoin
en l'autorité en a besoin pour voilà
pour mettre en place ses règles pour
mettre en place des mesures sécurité
routière tout ça par exemple
mais fondamentalement ça a pas vraiment
de sens ça ça nous donne l'illusion
qu'on peut chiffres et objectivement une
vie en fait alors que pas du tout c'est
pas possible
on a tous ceux qui veulent plus que
d'autres par exemple
la vie de ma mère elle vaut beaucoup
plus pour moi que pour vous et même des
fois ça te change et j'espère que je
sais pas vous devez par exemple sauver
deux personnes qui sont en train de se
noyer
un gars très vieux et un gars très jeune
a priori vous avez envie de sauver le
gars très jeune mais voilà vous rendez
compte qu'en fait le gars très vieux
vous le reconnaissez c'est un mec qui a
sauvé des familles pendant la Seconde
Guerre mondiale de la déportation il est
très très vieux ok et le jeune vous le
reconnaissez et c'est un sale killer que
vous avez vu dans le journal et donc là
bon bah vous voilà subjectivement les
valeurs de vie change donc c'est très
difficile de juger et de chiffres et une
vie de manière objective mais si on
quitte un instant d'abord la vie
cosmique puis la vie des autres et cette
activité et qu'on revient à la vie
individuelle
j'aime bien vivre ok
mais si je faisais que vivre
c'est-à-dire que par exemple être
enfermé dans une pièce
et rien faire
me nourrir et juste vivre en fait
je sais pas si c'est toi qui fait c'est
cool c'est que je fais les choses de ma
vie j'ai accompli des choses je
rencontre des gens
je vis des expériences
j'ai des joies des émotions et cetera
il se passe quelque chose au final
qu'est-ce que la vie faut pas
grand-chose en soi mescal la valeur
c'est ma façon d'exister c'est un peu ce
qu'il y a derrière le principe de Sartre
de l'existentialisme
l'existence précède l'essence pour
Sartre l'homme contrairement aux objets
n'est pas préfabriqué pour servir à
quelque chose par exemple
coque de téléphone elle a été fabriqué
est conçu pour protéger un téléphone
alors que nous les humains on est sur
terre condamné à être libre et en
fonction de ce qu'on fait de nos choix
de nos actions on détermine notre propre
valeur la vie on ou l'impôt j'ai sorti
manière ça qu'on arrive là on vit
parler distance et nous appartient
Sartre dit l'homme n'est rien d'autre
que ce qu'il se fait et c'est justement
pour ça qu'on veut pas lui donner une
valeur comment on fait avec une table
avec un canapé ou avec une coque de
téléphone la valeur d'une vie c'est
compliqué on l'a vu mais par contre la
valeur d'un téléphone ça c'est très
clair ok c'est le prix qu'on l'achète et
même pas en vrai c'est un petit peu faux
parce que il peut y avoir une valeur
sentimentale exetera bref on a envie de
protéger cette valeur là
tu parles de rhinoshield rhinoshield le
sponsor de cette vidéo vous en parle
maintenant parce que avec le Black
Friday il y a jusque moins 60 % sur le
site vous avez bien entendu - 60 % c'est
énorme et à sa ouvrir ajouter - 10 %
grâce au code Cyrus
BFM est-ce que vous savez nous sommes
pas à me laisser pour 6
- 65 - 10 % que le code en plus sur la
séance a beaucoup où trouver sur le site
des coques en vente plus les mérites
elles sont sans BPA BPLC bp FC des
substances chimiques qui peut être
dangereuse pour les femmes enceintes et
les bébés et évidemment c'est l'école
qui sont personnalisable mais aussi
personnalisé c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des
collections qui existent elle change
tout le temps là par exemple ce
[Musique]
qu' il y a même collection Star Wars en
silence avec il est tout noir mais en
fait c'est Dark Vador qui est dans une
autre texture de protection pour écran
de téléphone LD son pour écrans d'Apple
watch je l'ai déjà montré un extrait je
l'ai mise en rose et jaune et le cadran
je l'ai mis roses quand je vais la
rendre un peu funky exetera tac je mets
cette coque je mets sur 40 couleurs et
c'est parti quoi
c'était vraiment sur
Shield donc tu es pas concerné et les
protections pour airpods qui permet de
customiser donc votre petit boîtier
exetera voilà donc c'est à la fois la
protection à la fois la grosse mise à
Sion merci d'être sponsor cette vidéo
n'était pas encore une fois chez qui le
site jusqu'à - 70 % c'est pas tous les
quatre matins j'ai oublié de préciser
d'ailleurs mon code est valable 48
heures seulement donc
merci à eux merci nouvelle fois jusqu'au
bout love
Ciao